-Playing tonight, we have
the "Stranger Things" part
featuring Jimmy Fallon.
-That's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And their opponents, the othe
"Stranger Things" party
featuring Tariq Trotter.
-What, what, what,
what, what, what?
-Wow. All right, first up,
Jimmy and Finn.
Get on up here.
-Here we go.
-Now...here's how
the game works.
I'll read the start
of an Internet search query...
-Okay, yeah.
-...and you will
fill in the blank.
We have the top three most
popular answers on the board
You'll both type in answer
as fast as you can.
And then we'll see if they match
any of the top three.
-Okay. Is this from a poll -
a nationwide poll?
-Sure. Why not?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, nationwide.
Here's the first --
Here's the first search.
All right.
This is the question.
-My hands are as fast
as Bill Gates.
-There you go.
-Oh, mine's --
-I don't know if he types fast
I just know he knows computers
-Yeah, he does know computers.
-You're Mavis Beacon.
Okay, now, "Why did the '80s
have the worst blank?"
"Why did the '80s
What are the top three results
-Really?
-Everybody's ready?
Okay.
-Wow.
-You're on my team.
That's good.
-All right, Jimmy,
what did you write?
-But you're on his team.
-I'm sorry.
-All right, are we locked in
-You're locked in.
Is everybody locked in?
All right, Jimmy,
what did you write?
-I wrote hair.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
Finn, what did you write?
-I wrote clothes.
-Whoa.
Let's see the answers
on the board.
-Oh!
-Wowee!
Okay.
-We scored the same amount
of points.
I don't know what --
-Okay.
Ready? Yep?
-No, no, no, no, no.
-Yep.
-Okay, okay.
-Oh, hey, I'm on the team.
-What?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay.
-Okay.
-Yeah, potentially.
Okay.
-"Why did the '80s
have the worst..."
-Music.
-Do we see music?
-Whoa!
-Yeah!
Wowee.
Oh, my gosh.
-I disagree.
-The music from the '80s..
-I'm playing the game.
I'm playing the game.
We disagree, but we are playing.
-I disagree with my own answer
as well.
-Right.
You're just playing the game
-Don't be salty.
-Wow.
-Is that an English thing?
-Don't be salty?
-Salty?
-No, just don't be.
-Wow.
-Don't be salty.
-All right, Mr. Peanut.
Round two!
Millie, Caleb, you're up.
-All right, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, wow.
-Wow!
-Cold-blooded.
-It's all right.
-I love you, but no.
-Nah, nah.
I don't like you, so it's fine
-This is the game.
Here's the phrase.
"Will I regret eating
this whole blank?"
-I'm done.
-Oh, God.
-Okay, everybody's typing.
Everyone's typing.
-Do I press enter?
-Yep.
There you go. Ready?
Caleb, just type it in.
You're in.
-Yeah, it's so your credit
-Wait.
-Yeah, yeah, Caleb.
-That's it.
-Can you possibly do that?
-All right, ready?
-Yes, you can.
-Press return.
-Ready. Yeah.
-Everybody locked in?
-Yeah.
-Locked in.
-Millie, what did you write?
-Cake.
-Pizza pie.
Let's see the board.
-What?
-Oh!
Number-one answer.
Oh, my -- Oh, snap.
Oh, snap.
Oh, my God.
The mocking dance.
-We had that guy on our team
What are you going to do, Jimmy?
-All right, Gaten,
what are you going to say?
-Yeah, that guy.
-What do you think?
-That's the thing.
I can't tell.
I couldn't tell you.
-You got it. You got it.
"Will I regret eating
this whole..."
-Pint of ice cream.
Let's see it.
[ Cheering ]
Okay. One more, Tariq,
for the win.
-Ohh!
-To tie up the game.
"Will I regret eating
this whole..."
-Turkey?
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
Oh!
-Hey, hey.
-Wow.
Wow.
-That's a lot, though.
-That is a lot.
You're going to eat
a whole turkey.
That is a lot.
All righty.
-I'll give you $1,000
if turkey's up there.
-Let us see turkey.
Oh!
Now, you guys can steal.
Noah, what are you going to say?
It's up to you.
-Try it.
Just try it.
-I think it's going to be --
I think it's gonna be --
I -- What?
-Okay, I'm ready.
-Ready? What is it?
-No, no, it was his idea.
-All right.
Bag of chips.
-What?
-Will I regret eating
this whole bag of chips?
[ Cheering ]
Oh!
-But we got two, though.
But we got two, though.
-Okay, wow!
Bag o' chips.
-♪♪ Hello from the Upside Down
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-All right.
-Did you guys write a song
before coming here?
-Here's what's great about you
Here.
-Don't worry about it.
-I lost my name tag.
-What's great about me?
-Hey, here's
what's great about you.
Sorry.
All right, sorry.
-All right, it's time
for the final round.
-Thank you.
-This is for a billion points.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Noah and Gaten, you're up
You're up.
-All right, Gaten, you're up
-Come on, man.
-This is for the game.
-Do not let Noah win.
-Do not let Noah win?
-Yeah.
-This is for the game.
Ready?
-Don't type your name.
Don't type your name.
-I'm practicing.
-"Should I get a new blank?"
-Oh.
-Oh, oh.
-What is it?
-No, just --
-Car.
-Right, ready?
Type it in.
-No!
-This is for 1 billion points.
-Car.
-[ Screams ]
-Oh, no.
-Boyfr--
-Okay.
-No, Noah, Noah.
-No, don't put it.
-No, no, only put one.
You only get one.
-Keep going.
-Enter, enter!
-Yeah, click enter.
-No, don't.
You're clicking erase.
-Oh, my God.
-All right, just hang out.
-Apparently he wrote, "ohone,"
but phone.
We're gonna take phone.
Ohone. You got it.
-That can't count.
-That counts. Ohone counts
-Ohone can't count.
-It's the spirit of the law.
What did you write?
-I wrote car.
I wrote car.
-All right.
Car and phone.
[ Drumroll ]
Let's see them.
-Oh!
[ Cheering, shouting ]
-Oh, my God.
-My thanks to the cast
of "Stranger Things."